records show somebody sold this
apartment building at 9th and bridger
for 1.2 million dollars according to
court documents the seller was not a
managing member of the llc that actually
owns the building the company which tony
shay's estate now owns was the only one
with the authority to sell it
unfortunately fraud happens all the time
we ask shane jasmine young the owner and
an attorney at the young law group what
this all means there's always an
opportunity for someone to come in and
cause a problem try to steal
unfortunately you know we see that all
the time this document filed with the
court shows the transaction between the
llc and the buyer the document reveals
the person requesting the record is
listed as first american title with an
address at 4900 california avenue in
bakersfield but the company's real
address is in the 5000 block in addition
to the wrong address court documents say
the title officer's signature is forged
i would think that if someone a third
party was trying to do things you know
that were underhanded that they would
pay attention to the details we don't
know who the seller really is court
documents list him as a person named
santiago espinosa but that person is not
named in the secretary of state's
records for who really runs the building
the title has since returned to shea's
estate now lawyers are asking a judge to
clear the transaction altogether we
don't want to have issues down the road
that cloud the title for a sale in the
future lawyers for tony chai's estate
have never commented on these ongoing
issues about his wealth a court date is
scheduled for next week we're in
downtown las vegas i'm david charns 8
news now